good intentions the movie was directed
by Clint Eastwood and stars the
real-life heroes of a real-life event
that was almost a tragedy on a train to
Paris some brave men thwarted a
terrorist act a guy got on the train
with over 300 rounds of ammunition he
was about to start killing innocent
people and these guys worked together to
take this guy down and they succeeded
they were heroes it was all over the
news and Eastwood has made the
interesting choice of actually casting
the real-life people for these roles now
there's no doubt at all these guys are
heroes they're incredibly brave what
they did was monumentally important I
mean just a few weeks later Spencer
stone survived multiple stab wounds from
someone completely unrelated to this
event
he's like a specimen human you can't
hurt this guy he's like a terminator but
putting them in a movie directed by
Clint Eastwood released in theaters
nationwide is a different story and not
the best idea now it's also the easiest
thing to pinpoint as a problem with this
movie and there are a lot of them so
we're not gonna talk quite yet
about the acting because that's just the
most simple thing to talk about the real
issue here is a horrendously boring
story the important event in question
where they did take care of this
terrorist is very brief and so to tell a
compelling story and make us care they
have chosen to basically cover the bases
of their lives all the way back to
elementary school and we see them when
they're young and they first become
friends and we witness their training
and the different branches they have
chosen and we get to understand what
formed them into the type of people that
would make a split-second choice like
that on that train to save all of those
lives this is all understandable these
are the kind of things you would expect
to see in a movie like this but it's all
done in such a dull fashion where the
entire films emotional weight is so
muted that I just didn't really care
about the events they were portraying
even though I was looking at the real
people even though this is already one
of Eastwood shortest films you can feel
them straining to figure out what to do
with the story
there's like a 5-minute Skype
conversation with these guys where they
talk about going on this vacation the
vacation itself is one of the most
boring cinematic experiences I've
in the past few years they go to a party
they try gelato
they lollygag on a boat with a girl they
talked to some guy in a bar it's just
this endless string of selfie taking and
tourism activities and you just watch it
thinking to yourself what is this doing
for the story are we just supposed to
feel their lives and experience their
lives even in the smallest minutia
elements of them if that was the gold
and I understand that but it really does
not come across in a compelling way even
remotely so let's get into the acting
it's not very good and these are not
classically trained actors and so that's
not a surprise a lot of the blame here
should be placed on Eastwood's shoulders
because it's not just the real-life
heroes who aren't giving very good
performances the children early on in
the film also don't and one of them I've
seen in other movies wonder for instance
and he was good in wonder a lot of this
has to do with Eastwood's approach to
directing he has a very easy approach
very just move along and get the shots
he doesn't even like to call action he
likes to say you go ahead and stuff like
that instead of action he's known for
his very calming sets and his easygoing
rapport with actors and that's all very
good but when you have people who've
never really acted before that's not
good a lot of these performances feel
like the type of work I got out of
myself and my friends when we were
teenagers making movies you can feel
when they know the scenes over like the
last line they say feels like okay we're
done now and they walk off frame or the
scene ends and you're and you're
thinking yourself okay they knew they
were done that was the last line there's
no natural flow of dialogue it feels
like a very rehearsed series of events
which all films are a rehearsed series
of events but the magic in movies is
when they don't feel like that that's
movie magic you watch a planned event
that somehow feels spontaneous and this
entire film feels coordinated in the
worst way the biggest issue I had with
this really has nothing to do with a
that I watched a movie with some pretty
bad acting I feel like it's embarrassing
for these guys I feel like they deserve
better than this
because now there's just gonna be a lot
of people dissecting their performances
when that should not be something they
have to deal with they've already done
something incredibly heroic they're all
very brave and we shouldn't really be
sitting here wondering if they're gonna
be great in a movie directed by Clint
Eastwood that's just kind of strange to
me but here we are I paid for a ticket
and I went and saw it and now I'm
talking about their performances
unfortunately I found this to be one of
Clint Eastwood's worst films I thought
the emotion was very fake the actual
event on the train had some tense
moments but the way it's edited inter
splice throughout the film cutting back
to their childhood or to their adult
lives was very awkward and I guess
that's really the best word to describe
this entire film awkward I'm gonna give
the 1517 to Paris adhi this film
reminded me of active valor do you
remember that movie where they had real
Navy SEALs portraying Navy SEALs in a
film sure that got all of the technical
stuff correct and nobody knows how to
play them better than them but as a film
has a piece of entertainment that was
probably not the best idea same with
this movie guys thank you so much as
always for watching I look forward to
more reviews very soon if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man iced
[Music]